واعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الباكستانيه في
بيان رسمي استهداف مواقع لمجموعات وصفتها
بالارهابي داخل الاراضي الايرانيه وذلك
غداه تنفيذ طهران ضربات داخل باكستان
وقالت ان الجيش نفذ سلسله ضربات عسكريه
على مخابئ ارهابيين في اقليم سستان
بلوشستان الايراني واضافت انه تم اطلاع
طهران على المواقع المستهدفه مؤكده ان هذه
الضربات كانت دفاعا عن امن البلاد واوضحت
الوزاره ان اسلام باد تحترم سياده ايران
ووحده اراضيها وانها ستواصل مساعيها
لايجاد حلول مشتركه معها ضد الارهاب وشددت
الوزاره على ان الحكومه الباكستانيه
ستواصل اتخاذ جميع الخطوات اللازمه
للحفاظ على سلامه وامن
شعبها
معنا من اسلام اباد مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد
الرحمن مطر معك عبد الرحمن مطر ماذا بعد
بيان وزاره الخارجيه ان كانت بيانات اخرى
قد صدرت لتوضيح ما جرى في
سروان نحن ننتظر بعد قليل انعقاد مؤتمر
صحفي للمتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه ربما
لاعطاء مزيد من التفاصيل لكن بالتاكيد
باكستان غاضبه وغاضبه للغايه منذ يوم امس
ومنذ ان اقدمت ايران على اختراق الاجواء
الباكستانيه وتوجيه الضربه في منطقه
حدوديه داخل الاراضي الباكستانيه بالامس
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الباكستانيه انها
سحبت سفيرها من من ايران وان السفير
الايراني الذي كان في اجازه في طهران لن
يعود حاليا الى العاصمه اسلاماباد وايضا
الخارجيه الباكستانيه قالت يوم امس بانها
اوقفت وعلقت كل اللقاءات الثنائيه رفيعه
المستوى بين حكومتي البلدين ووزير
الخارجيه بالامس قال في اتصال هاتفي مع
نظيره الايراني قال له بان باكستان تحتفظ
لنفسها بحق الرد وان المسؤوليه كامله تقع
على الجانب الايراني اثر تنفيذها تلك
الغاره فجر يوم امس هنا داخل الاراضي
الباكستانيه اليوم جاء الرد من باكستان
وزاره الخارجيه اكدت تنفيذ الجيش
الباكستاني لسلسله من الغارات داخل
الاراضي الباكستانيه الايرانيه عفوا فيما
ان المصادر الموثوقه اكدت لنا بانه تم ضرب
على الاقل سته الى سبعه اهداف في ثلاث
مواقع بعمق 40 الى 50 م داخل الاراضي
الايرانيه وانه تم اطلاع الجانب الايراني
على تلك الاهداف واطلاع الجانب الايراني
سابقا عن عن تلك المواقع
لارهابيين داخل الاراضي الايرانيه وان
ايران لم تتخذ اي اجراء ضد تلك المواقع ما
اضطر باكستان اليوم لتنفيذ هذه الضربات
التي استخدمت فيها الصواريخ الموجهه عاليه
الدقه وايضا الطائرات المسيره اذا الحديث
هنا في باكستان عن ان سياسيا دبلوماسيا تم
سحب السفراء وتم ايقاف وتعليق كل اللقاءات
الثنائيه فيما على المستوى العسكري تم
الرد والرد على ما يبدو انه كان قاسم
للغايه داخل الاراضي الايرانيه لا سيما
وان الضربه الايرانيه للاراضي الباكستانيه
تسببت في كثير من الغضب هنا في باكستان
واسلام باات تحديدا مطرها اليوم لتنفيذ
هذه السلسله من الغراد داخل الاراضي
الايرانيه للتاكيد على سيادتها الوطنيه
ولتاكيد على استعدادها لحمايه حدودها
واجوائها واراضيها نعم